I’ve assembled the greatest con men in the NFL
Do just well enough to get the money
then your talent disappears
But Fitzy, you’ve stolen millions
from the Rams, Bengals, Bills, Titans, Texans, Jets
What else is there?
I’m going to steal the starting QB job for the Bucs
Here’s the plan
I cause a distraction in the media
Ahem-
I went to Harvard
but I’m wearing silly clothes
Wow! Look!
Next we need a QB controversy
That’s where Sammy Sleeves comes in
Whoops
maybe you should start the rookie!
Dalton, Marvin
I need you to get people excited
but still lose a Wild Card game
The AFC North is really up for grabs
At this point
no one will know what it takes to be an NFL quarterback
And if I play one good half, I’ll get the job
Now eventually, I'll be exposed
Uh, sir
you’re going to want to see this
Only I get to be overpaid
Get him!
Tannehill
that’s when you confuse everybody
Uhhhhhhhh-
they are 3-0 uhhh
And they’ll have to start me anyway
Any questions?
Why don’t we just play great football all the time?
Because that’s so hard